واصل من السودان حيث قال رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهاني من القوات
المسلحه تساند اتفاق السلام في اقليم
النيل الازرق من جانبه قال وزير الماليه
باقليم النيل الازرق ان اكثر من 100000
لاجئ عادوا الى منطقه اوله من اثيوبيا
ودوله جنوب السودان وهم في حاجه لمساعده
انسانيه
الازرق مراسل الجزيره هيثم اهلا بك ضعنا
ايضا في الصوره واخر التطور
نعم هذه الزياره المهمه لرئيس مجلس
السياده لمنطقه قولوا وهي معقله الحركه
الشعبيه التي كانت تحتها سيطره الحركه
الشعبيه طوال سنوات الحرب الماضيه لن
نصف قرن من الزمان هذه المنطقه لم يزورها
مسؤول رفيعه مثل هذه الزياره هذه زياره
اتت لي الوقوف على الاوضاع الانسانيه همم
الجانب الاول وتقديم الدعم العائدين من
رحله الوجوه من دول الجواهر من الجنوب
السودان او اثيوبيا او النازحين داخليا
وعدوا الى مناطقم الامر الثاني هو الوقوف
على بند الترتيبات الامنيه الواقع في
اتفاق بين الموقع بين الحركه الشعبيه
والحكومه السودانيه ضمن هذا الاتفاق هناك
بنده الترتيبات الامنيه الذي يقضي بالدم
بقوات الحركه الشعبيه في الجيش السوداني
الجيش القومي بدات المرحله الاولى الان
يتم الترتيب للمرحله الثانيه التي ستنطلق
قريبا بعد تخريج هذه القوات هكذا الجيش
يقف مع الاقليم في هذه اه ظروفها عوده
الناجحين واللاجئين وايضا تقديم المساعدات
لهم خاصه ان العدد كبير جدا من الناجحين
واللاجئين كذلك اكد انه سيعمل على اتمام
هذه الاتفاق اتفاق جوبا لسلام وصولا
لتحقيق غاياته المرجوع من قبل المواطنين
والشعب الاقليم ان نستمع الى الكلمه التي
ادلى بها الفريق البرهان في هذا الحفل
الجماهيري
منها دعمها لنا اللاجئين ودعمه هل
الناجحين والتاكيد لهم بان نحن حنقيص معه
ونقطه صحيحه والتاكيد ايضا لا اخونا مالك
ولكل الناس القائمين على امر السلام نحن
صليفه لانه اتفاق السلام ده يجب ان يتحقق
لانه المكاسي والجات منه ما خلص من الناس
اخصمها يتمنوه
من خلاله يواصلوا معيشتهم الطبيعيه
ويكونوا ناس فاعلين في المجتمع مع
السوداني وفي الدوله السودانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا هيثم اوي كنت معنا من
التمازيم بالنيل الازرق